it's talking about that number sixteen
sixteen is a very session with me it's
my actual favorite number one of my
favorite numbers is sixteen and a lot of
people seem to like sixteen even though
it is an even number it winds up being a
square number it's partially favorite
because I was born on the 16th day of
December to be precise and I always
liked it because when I was sweet 16 on
the 16th I could do a lot of things by
then I could go off and get married if I
wanted to I could leave school legally I
did of course but 16 is also
mathematically very special it's the
square of a perfect square did you know
that no would you like me to explain
yeah of course
okay yes a perfect square a good example
is 2 squared 2 squared you get 4 it's
perfect because I've got 2 to the power
2 it's the same digit if I Square this
so all of that squared so this is 4
squared lo and behold we get 16 my
favorite number and I was at a pub once
with some friends of mine and we were
drinking and having fun and we thought
would order some food we were on table
16 I went up to the bar I said ah to get
through could we get delivered to 16 I
went oh wait a minute which is which is
4 squared can I can i order food to the
table 4 squared and the poor girl behind
the bar look very confused now we don't
know actually
we'll make it easier how about I order
it 2 2 to the 4 because not only is 16 4
times 4 it's also 2 times 2 times 2
times 2 and then at this point she
looked very bewildered and later on we
managed to intercept her food on the way
to table 24 let's say I have the
relationship X raised to the power of y
so x and y are two different integer
numbers so X cannot equal Y so X could
be 2 Y could be 3 we'd have 2 cubed now
the only relation that is satisfied by
this number 16 is that X to the Y
equal to Y to the X so the number on
this side of your equal sign is gonna be
exactly the same as the number on this
side of the equal sign to do that I'm
gonna take the number X is gonna be
let's say 4 and let's take Y to be 2 if
we interpret those onto the other side
of the equation y was 2 and X was 4 4 to
the power 2 we've already seen it 16 to
raise that to the power 4 you put it
into your calculator what do you get 16
and 2 and 4 are the only numbers that
can be interpreted as X's and y in order
to get this relationship this special
number 16 we thought there must there
must be other numbers and we had a bit
of a chat and we realized none of us
knew and we all do math things for a
living we thought well let's well let's
work it out we decided cuz you could you
could look it up we could go online and
see if anyone else to try this and we
thought no it's it's as much fun to work
this out as if no one else ever has and
some people went away and so trying to
write computer software to see if there
are bigger ones and the rest of us were
like some people drawing graphs that we
were doing number theory stuff and a lot
of prime factors since suddenly appeared
on other people because this went across
many evenings other people are like what
are you guys doing or like we're trying
to work out if 16 is the only number
where you can write it to X to the Y or
Y to the X you cannot get any other
number using any other integers to get a
number that equals itself 16 is the only
number and we've since realized other
people do know about this and
it's a nice property of sixteen but we
had the joy of working it out for
ourself and so if you get bored you can
check why and it's fascinating why 16 is
the only number that does that that's
pretty cool I think so
it was initially it was just a lot of
arguing over food so people walking by
just Saurus eating and someone would go
but what about 64 and then they'll be a
bit matter and it's nice we go no no not
64 now okay we're back to the food is
that why it's your favorite number or is
it just cuz your birthday this is just a
cool relationship often during lessons
we'd be like what if it's and then
someone would go I've got a log check
out this log grab this is this is it
well I don't know and actually this was
the beginning if I can get distracted
briefly this was the beginning of
something called maths Jam which is a
organisation I rommel people get
together in a pub and do maths because
we realized we started off in this pub
drinking and we accidentally did maths
and then later on we were doing more and
more and other puzzles started to show
up we realized that 36 is both a square
number and a triangle number but that's
a whole different video and we certainly
thought why are we having these debates
when we're meant to be teaching school
kids why don't we get rid of the school
kids and just replace them with tasty
beverages and so ever since and now it's
all around the world their last count 14
or 15 different cities in the UK and
other countries have mass jams where
people get together on the second last
Tuesday of the month and talk about
maths and do problems and play with toys
and yet all because I sat down in a pub
at table 16